con un poco más de 776 mil contagios por
kobe 19 y un promedio de 16.000 nuevos
casos en las últimas 48 horas el
gabinete del presidente francés emmanuel
macrón se reúne para fijar nuevas
estrategias estaría analizando extender
los confinamientos sectorizados en
varias regiones que el curso esquiva
está aumentando lentamente y de forma
masiva y justo como con otras
enfermedades a veces piensas que tienes
tiempo para mitigarlas pero al final es
una carrera contrarreloj y es ahí donde
estamos estamos en una carrera
contrareloj complementó el número de
hospitalizaciones superó las 1500 el
pasado lunes un récord que no se daba
antes del 27 de mayo la situación no es
diferente en otros lugares de europa en
italia que tiene en el momento una
medida de casos diarios de 5500 se
anunció que bares y restaurantes deben
cerrar a medianoche y se prohíbe en los
partidos de aficionados de deporte de
contacto además de las fiestas privadas
sólo perfectamente deporte estoy en
acuerdo con el gobierno porque nadie
puede saber cuán malo es este virus así
que es mejor ser cauteloso y actuar a
tiempo
motors en precisamente una medida
similar en república chica que además se
extiende las restricciones al cierre
inmediato de todos los colegios este
país fue uno de los más exitosos en
contención de la pandemia por cada
100.000 habitantes
alemania cuenta este martes con más de
4.100 casos en medio de un fuerte debate
por la prohibición a los viajeros de las
zonas de riesgo del país de pernoctar en
su territorio el ascenso de casos en
europa sigue en aumento imparable a
pesar de las fuertes medidas de
bioseguridad